MATTEO VALLONE: Hi, everyone.
My name is Matteo Vallone, and
I work in the Google Play Games
business element
team here in London.
So now we're going
to talk about one
of the most
important topics when
it comes to running your
game as a service, which
is what users should
you run the service for.
And what I mean by that
is that you monetize
your game with in-app
purchases and the game is
free to install, you always face
this challenge that on one side
you want as many
users as possible
to come in, download
your game, and try it.
On the other side, the
more users you have
and the more-- sorry,
I need a-- yeah.
The more users you have, the
more diverse they will be.
You will find casual users,
hard core users together.
Some will come for the PVP.
Some will come for PVE, and
some will have bigger budgets
to spend and some will be a bit
more concerned about spending.
So the wider the funnel,
the more difficult
it is to please everyone.
And that's what we're
going to talk about
in the next 30 minutes.
So, first of all,
Adam, my colleague,
who is a game
design expert, will
talk about the basics of
running your game as a service,
and also some key
design principles
to make sure that every player,
regardless of their profile
and what they're looking
for, finds value in your game
and is engaged.
Then Fred from
Space Ape will talk
about how they
approach monetization
for these different
cores of users.
How do they target
them and make sure
that they extract the LTV
that they bring to the game?
They've been improving
this over time.
And so, Fred will
give you an overview
of how all the different
steps that they
take and all the learnings that
they acquired in that process,
and also give you a sneak
peek into viewing into what
is coming next for them.
But Space Ape wasn't
built in a day.
It takes time and effort.
And so that's why I'm
going to come back on stage
and talk about
some tools that can
get you started right away,
applying this concept in a very
simple way, and also free,
which is always good.
So lots of content, and so,
Adam, please take it away.
ADAM GUTTERMAN: Hi, everyone.
Thank you, Matteo,
for that lovely intro.
Thank you, Shannon,
for hosting today.
And thank you all for coming
out to Playtime London.
I know it's a gorgeous
day in London,
so thank you all for
spending it with us.
I'm very excited
to be here today.
This is my second Playtime,
second time in London for this,
and LTV is one of my
favorite subjects,
so super stoked to talk
to you about it today.
As Matteo was
mentioning, let's go just
through a little
bit of the basics
when it comes to LTV,
just so we can level
set before Fred from Space
Ape is going to come up here
and give you the
master class on it.
So, let's do LTV 101 for a bit.
Know your metrics.
All right, what is LTV
and why does it matter?
LTV simply stands
for Life Time Value.
If you didn't know
that, now you do.
It's one of the key metrics
that everyone looks at when
it comes to game development.
It's something that you
buy against when you're
doing your user
acquisition campaigns,
and it's obviously what
you look to when you're
trying to monetize your games.
This is the absolute value
of the average custom
in your game.
Now, it's a bit
different in games
as a service, which you often
see in mobile, versus what
you would ordinarily see
in a packaged business
that you would see, say, in
GameStop or somewhere else.
In a packaged games business,
you've got a binary outcome.
You either have $0 or you have
$60 from your customer-- one
or the other,
nothing in between.
With games as a service,
it's a bit different.
There's no barrier to entry.
People come in.
It's free to download.
And then you have
this experience
where you're providing
a service as the player
goes through your game.
So LTV is not a function
of a single price point.
LTV is a function of
engagement times the value
that you offer your
customers and the value
that they give you back
in terms of dollars.
So LTV in this case,
for games as a service,
is engagement times value.
So, Fred's going to come up in
a minute and talk about value.
He's got some
amazing slides on it.
I'm going to talk about
engagement really quickly,
just to talk about how do
developers drive engagement,
think about it, and measure it.
So let's think about
measuring it first.
There's a few ways to
measure engagement.
There is the traditional
ways of session length
and sessions per day, and
that stickiness factor
that you often hear
about-- daily active users
over monthly active users.
Hint-- that should
be at least 15%.
But hard retention,
hard retention
is one that we look at all the
time-- D1, D7, D30-- absolutely
critical.
And it's critical for a
very, very obvious reason,
but I'm going to
tell you it just
to make sure it sticks
and you never forget it.
You can't make money
from your users.
You can't offer them value
and they can't give you value
back in terms of their
dollars if they're not
playing the game.
So if your D7 and D30s are
low, if players are not
sticking around in your
game, simply-- again,
very obviously,
you're not going to be
able to make money from them.
This is why it's absolutely
one of the most critical things
out there.
It's the number one predictor
of success in LTV is retention.
Now, what about benchmarks?
People ask us this all the time.
So, as a platform, we talk
to every game developer
out there that we can.
We look at casual games.
We'll look at mid-core games.
We look at core games.
And, yeah, take pictures
of the slide all you want.
This is a good one.
Retention is paramount,
but the benchmarks
are absolutely 100% paramount.
You can be in this darker
area, blue at the bottom
or-- but what you
really want to do
is be in the sky blue
on top, because that's
the cream of the crop up there,
the best games out there.
Those are their retention rates.
So if you're in the core genre
like a super, super core MMO,
something like
"Hearthstone" or something
like that-- I'm not saying
this is their retention rate
but something in
that core area--
you want to be at least 10%,
pushing above that even better,
all the way up to casual.
I have one developer who has
been working on a casual game
now, and they will not
ship the casual game
until their D30 retention
rate is 23%, best in class.
Because they know that
that retention rate is
the key predictor
of the lifetime
value of their customers
and of their game.
Absolutely important.
Oh, and by the way, we've got
tools to help you measure this.
Who here uses Play Game
Services in their game?
Yeah?
Do you use the Player Stats API?
Some of you do.
More of you should.
Remember this.
Player Stats API will actually
help you measure retention.
One thing though, encourage
sign in for your game.
Have it in a really good
place, because the more people
sign, the more data
you're going to get.
You want to be pushing 50%,
60% sign-in in your game.
That way you can actually
measure as many people
as you can coming
through your game.
OK, so, we've talked
about how to measure
engagement and retention.
Awesome stuff.
How do we actually engage
and retain players?
Let's do this really
quickly before we have Fred
come up and talk about value.
Who here has played
"Clash Royale?"
I want all the hands to go up.
Yeah, awesome, an amazing game.
It's topical, because it
just launched this year,
and everybody loves this game.
Let's talk about the way
that they engage players.
Now, a game shouldn't
engage players the same way
for every single player.
A game should have
very different ways
to engage players, to engage
your more casual players,
the players that play
maybe once or twice
a day, the ridiculously
core players, the guy that
is glued to his phone or
has a battery pack walking
around playing "Pokemon Go"
because he can't put it down,
and everything else in between.
You want your game to engage
players in every different way,
and every different cadence,
every different kind of play
style.
So, let's look at
how "Clash" does it.
Here on the left, you
see the card shop.
This card shop refreshes
once every 24 hours.
I know that, because I
get a little notification,
and I go to the card
shop every 24 hours
to see what they've
been serving me.
And it's personalized to me.
It's different to everybody.
And I want to see what's there,
because I might be looking
for that rare lumberjack
card, and it comes up,
and I want to buy it.
So, on the minimum
on a daily basis,
I'm like, well, I got to check
what cards are new, absolutely.
So I'm encouraged
to log in every day.
Look at the rate.
This is the battle screen.
You got this on-demand mode.
I can battle randomly a
player right now as many times
as I want, so it's on demand.
It is for the most core players,
for the most casual player.
It is on demand.
It is not on a clock.
But there's other things
here on this screen
that are actually on clocks.
There's a couple of things.
There's a chest
going on over here
that's going to open in
two hours and 21 minutes.
There's a free
chest that's going
to be available in three
hours and 21 minutes.
So, you can kind of see
what they're doing here.
You've got this daily
engagement mechanic.
You've got this
on-demand mechanic.
You've got these chests
opening at different times.
Over here, you've got
tournaments that start and end
in various different cadences.
And on the far
right here, you've
got this every two
weeks the season is up,
and you earn rewards for
yourself and for your clan.
You can see what
"Clash" is doing here,
what Supercell is doing.
They're trying to engage
players in every way
possible that they want
to engage with the game
to the most casual to
everything in between,
all the way up to the most core.
Thank you very much.
I'm going to bring Fred Easey.
Up here to talk about value,
master class, and LTV.
Everybody, welcome Fred
Easey from Space Ape.
FRED EASEY: Thank you, Adam.
Hi.
My name is Fred Easey.
I head up the analytics
team at Space Ape Games.
I should put my slide on.
So, we are a mid-core
studio based just
around the corner
from here in Soho.
We've got three live games.
They're all in the
build and battle genre.
So, if you've played
"Clash of Clans,"
any of those kind of
games, you build a base.
You attack other people.
They attack you.
Those are the types
of games that we make.
And over the years,
we've had a challenge
trying to monetize
players in those games.
And today, I want to talk about
the past, how we used to do it.
I want to talk about
the present, how
we're doing things now.
And we're going to take
a look at the future
as Matteo alluded
to, and what we're
going to be doing pretty
soon in terms of how are
we going to monetize people.
So, let's cast our
minds back to 2013.
And we're launching
our first game.
It's "Samurai Siege."
It was a fast follow
on "Clash of Clans"
with some additional
improvements added on.
And this screen here is showing
you the shop in the game.
So, this is how users
buy currency in the game.
They go to the shop, and there's
a range of different prices
they can buy.
And if you spend
more in the shop,
if you're buying one of
these high-value ones,
you get more in-game
currency back.
You're getting a better bang
for your buck, in effect.
So, we're trying to encourage
people to spend a bit more.
So, with the shop, what are
the pros and cons of this?
So there's a range of prices.
So players will generally
be able to buy a price
that they're willing to
spend at, which is good.
Also, there's the bulk
discount that I mentioned,
which is going to encourage
players to maybe move up
a notch in terms of how
much they wanted to spend.
So, that's going to upsell.
One downside is we
found with this system,
players will tend
to stick around
the same sort of
transaction size.
So, if they come
in, they spend $20,
they tend to stay around
that level, generally.
The other really bad
thing about the shop
is it's kind of tucked away.
If you go into the game
and you want to spend,
it's two or three clicks deep.
You've got to click on one
thing to bring up a menu,
then there's another
click to get to the shop,
then you go to click
to get the buy screen.
It's a lot of clicks.
It's quite high friction.
So you're going to lose some
spends there, basically.
So, this system is
actually very popular.
It's still used today by a lot
of really big games-- "Clash
Royale," as we've just
seen, "Pokemon Go."
These are number
one grossing games,
and this is pretty much
how those guys do it.
This way works really
well, so there's
no shame in having
a set up like this.
But we want to try
to improve this.
So one thing we added
to "Samurai Siege"
was time-limited bundles.
So we're going
forward in time here.
It's the Iron Age.
And with these bundles, what
would happens is the player
would log into the game,
and this would pop up.
It's a special offer.
Now, you've only got so
long to purchase this.
There will be a countdown,
so maybe there's
five hours, 24 hours,
something like that.
So, there's pressure there.
You've got to buy it now
or it's going to go away,
and it's gone.
And it's really good value.
So if we look at this bundle
here in "Samurai Siege,"
you're getting some diamonds,
which is the in-game currency.
You can only get that
through spending dollars--
well, high amounts
of it, anyway.
We've got onyx, which is
another currency which is
very valuable to the players.
It lets them buy camps,
which gives them troops.
And we've also got this
sun dragon's tower,
which is an actual
camp that they
can deploy in the game--
quite a powerful thing.
Each of these separate things
is worth about 10 pounds,
something like that-- 10
pounds for the diamonds,
10 pounds for the
onyx, 10 pounds
for the sun dragon tower.
So, overall, they're
getting about 30 pounds
of value for 19 pounds, so
it's a pretty great deal.
This is a term that we call
EV, or Estimated Value.
And that's a percentage-- in
this case, about 150 to 200%--
of how much better it is than
what you'd get from spending
in the store.
So, with this kind of deal,
you've go a lot of good things
which are going to make
the player want to buy it.
You've got the
timer ticking down.
You've got the great value.
You've got some nice art there.
All of these things
are going to help.
So we found when
we launched this
that we had a big uptick
in conversion and spend,
so it was a great way to
try and convert people.
A couple of dangers
with these things-- one
is that players can become
trained to wait for these.
So what's the point
in buying in a shop
if you know that one of these
is going to spawn tomorrow?
You might as well
wait, get your value.
So you'll tend to see that shop
spend is cannibalized a bit.
The other thing you'll see
as well is content burn.
You are giving away
more for the same price,
so you're going to burn
through your content
more quickly than if players
are just buying from the shop.
So there's that to
think about as well.
And one other thing-- and this
is probably the most important
thing I'll say about these.
They work really well when you
combine them with a live event.
By a live event, what I mean
is a special event in the game.
So, for these build
and battle games,
you want to have a special
event running on the weekend
where you'll be competing
against other alliances
as part of your own can
trying to beat each other.
And if you theme this
offer with the event,
you'll see a real big
surge in your sales.
People love that, basically.
They want to spend anyway,
because it's an event.
You're showing them
a great bundle.
A lot of people are going
to spend at that point.
So, just to
illustrate that, this
is a graph of revenue over time
for "Rival Kingdoms," which
is the second game we launched.
And what you'll see is
these two peaks in revenue
that I've highlighted
here and here, those
are events which were teamed
up with a great bundle,
a great event, great bundle.
And you can see that there's
a real surge in revenue
during that.
One thing I'll say
is you don't want
to do that every week,
because otherwise you're just
going to fatigue
players, and you
won't have as strong an effect.
But it's something we
try and do something
like once a month
in our games is
we'll have one
these great bundles,
one of these great
events, and we'll always
see a big surge in
sales as a result.
So that's time-limited bundles.
That's how we used to do things.
We still run a lot of these
things in our games as well.
These haven't gone away, but
we've added stuff over time.
So, let's take up to the
present day-- Steam Age--
timeline bundles.
So we've got a screenshot here.
This is "Transformers
Earth Wars,"
which is the most recent
game that we've launched.
This is an example of one of
the bundles which is popping.
We've got some nice
Transformer art on there.
What is a timeline bundle--
no one said-- but I'm
going to answer that question.
Here are some timelines.
So each row on this table
represents a timeline.
Now, it's a little bit
blurred, but on the left here,
there's different spend
segments, in effect.
so we've got non-spender, low
mid-spender, high-spender,
all the way up to
high-spender II, which
is the really big one.
What this represents is
what a person's maximum
spend has been into the
game up to that point.
So if you come in and you're
playing for the first time,
you're going to
be a non-spender.
If you go in to shop, for
example, you spend $20.
Now, we're going to class
you as a mid-spender.
And what happen is,
with this system,
we've got a series of
bundles that we've worked out
that we think that will
be appealing to users
in those segments.
And what will happen is, each
time they log in each day,
they're going to get shown
one of these bundles.
They might buy it.
They might not.
They might buy it and move
up to a higher timeline.
The next day, they're
going to log in.
They're going to see another
one of these bundles,
a different one.
And sometimes at
these higher levels,
it will even go
faster than one a day.
You might see a couple in a day.
And this is much more effective
than the other version
I was showing you for
a number of reasons.
So, why does this work better?
It's better upselling than
a single price point bundle.
With a single
price point bundle,
you've got this tension
where you've got
to decide what price to put up.
So for those
time-limited bundles,
if you are the guy
running the game,
you are like I'm going to run
a $10 bundle this weekend.
With a $10 bundle,
a lot of people
will buy it, because
it's quite a low price,
so a lot people can afford it.
But there are some guys
who wanted to spend 50.
You know, the guys
loved the game.
They want to play all weekend.
They want a $50 bundle.
And they're going
to buy your $10 one.
So you left money
on the table there.
And the flipside is if you run
the $40 bundle or $50 bundle,
there's a lot of
guys who don't want
to spend that much on a mobile
game-- most people, in fact--
and they're not going to buy it.
So again, you're leaving
money on the table.
With this system, your
showing the correct bundle
to the correct user.
The non-spender's seeing
the low value ones.
The high spender's
seeing the high value.
So it's tailored to
what the customer wants.
The other thing as well,
there's no curation
required after initial setup.
So obviously,
there's quite a lot
of work in setting
up these timelines.
Once it's done, it's done.
With the other type
I was showing you,
those time-limited
ones, every week you'll
have new art created.
You've got to decide what
bundle you're going to run,
all that kind of stuff.
With this, it's
essentially automatic.
It's automated once it's set up
so no real intervention needed.
What we found with this system
is the games make two to three
more in terms of lifetime
value when you add this.
We'd actually run a split
test in "Transformers"
doing the soft launch, where we
had this system versus players
not having the system.
And, yeah, it was 2 to 3x
increase in lifetime value.
So this is tried
and tested for us.
It really works.
The other thing as well
is this isn't instead
of the other stuff I
showed you, the shop
and the time-limited bundle.
You can have all
three in your game.
And in fact, we have
all three in our game,
and they serve
different purposes.
The shop's there for the
really intense players who
want to spend the whole time.
They're not going to
wait for special offer.
They want their stuff now.
They can go to shop.
They're going to spend.
We've got these
timeline bundles,
where players will log in
almost on like a daily thing
with a login, see the
bundle, and think, mm,
that's a good one.
Yeah, I'm going to buy that one.
And then we've also got
the time-limited bundle
which we'll set up
with those events,
as I was saying, where
they're timed with the event
and will get those big
spikes on the weekends
and that kind of thing.
The dangers with these ones
is pretty much the same
as the time-limited bundles.
You've got that problem
about content burn.
You've got that problem about
cannibalization from the shop.
But net-net overall,
you're still
going to make a lot more
money using this system
despite those drawbacks.
So this is one thing I'll just
mentioned in passing quickly.
This is a correlation matrix for
people who know what that is.
We're basically--
at the moment, we
target these things based
on the user's max spend.
So if you've spent
$20 ever, you'll
go into that middle
spender bracket,
even if you normally spend $5.
You go, 5, 5, 5, 5, then 20.
At that point, you go into
the middle spender bracket,
and that's where
you're going to stay.
We did a quick thing
where we looked
at the correlation between what
your next spend amount is going
to be, so this far-left
column, and all of these other
spend metrics, if we
know about the user.
So we've got the mean of
all your previous spends.
We've got the median,
the mode, for people
who know what that is,
the max the lifetime
sum of all of them.
And actually, the
one which correlated
the best, although it wasn't
like a winner by miles,
was the mean spend.
So that's one of
the things which
you're going to be doing in the
short term to improve these.
We're going to switch
away from max spend,
and we're going to move on to
mean spend because we think
that will be better at guessing
how much people want to spend.
So we've talked about
the present in our games.
Now we're going to have a
little look to the future.
So the Rocket Age--
targeted bundles.
So imagine that we've got
all these different bundles
that you can buy in the game.
So there's some for
$5, some for $1, $10.
There's different types.
I've got a battle
bundle, which will
help me battle in the game.
I'm might even build
a bundle, which
is good for building
stuff in the game, all
that kind of stuff.
So what we'd like to
do, and we've actually
started work on this
already, is we're
going to development
a machine learning
approach, where we look at
a user's purchase history.
We'll run it through a
machine learning algorithm,
work out what price
fits them really well.
And that's going to
narrow down what bundles
we're going to show them.
So if you think you
want to spend $20,
you can chuck away the
twenties, the ones, the fives.
There's now going to be a subset
of these $20 bundles which
we know that you want to buy.
Then we look at the
different types, so something
like a resource
bundle, where you're
buying currency in the game.
If the player is
running low on currency,
they're probably going to
be more likely to buy that.
With a battle bundle, if
you're running an event where
you need to battle
a load, they're
probably going to be
more likely to want that
at that point in time.
So we're then going
to factor that in
as well in deciding
which bundle to show you.
And we're going to
choose the one which
we think you've got the
highest chance to buy relative
to its price.
So if you got a 10% chance
of buying the $100 bundle,
that's better than if
you've got 20% chance
of buying the $20 bundle,
if that makes sense.
So we're going to see you
the one we think we're
going to get the most revenue.
So that's the plan with this.
As I mentioned, we
started building this.
We tried a few
different approaches.
At the moment, we're
trying a nearest neighbors
model, which is working pretty
well for getting the price.
And we think that
this is really going
to take things to the
next level in terms
of how well the system works.
One last thing
I'll add on this is
that you should include a
random element when you're
deciding which bundle to show.
I know that sounds a
bit weird because you're
like, why put all this
effort into deciding
what price we're going to show
and which type's going to sell?
But sometimes you can
refer to a random element.
The reason is I found with
using these types of systems
in the past, is
if you just leave
it completely to the
algorithm, sometimes
it would just keep
showing the guy
the same bundle,
which is kind of weird
and not a good
customer experience.
So it's good to have a
random element, some kind
of random element,
just so there's
some variety and
freshness that still
comes into what you're rotating
and showing to the user.
So that's the Rocket Age.
And now I'm going to
hand over to Matteo,
who's going to talk about some
of the Google tools which can
help you do this kind of stuff.
[APPLAUSE]
MATTEO VALLONE: So
that's hard to follow.
That's really interesting stuff.
And as you can see,
it's not easy stuff.
So that's why I'm here.
I'm just relaxing.
You don't have to be
in the Rocket Age.
you can start with
some simple tools.
And hopefully the
tools that we build
will get you started not
at the Stone Age, but maybe
the Steam Age.
So you already have a way
to target users and optimize
your LTV without having all
this technology and resources
already invested in it.
So let's start with the
first tool that I think
is very relevant
here when it comes
to optimizing your game
design and engaging
different types of users.
This is the Time Series page
in your developer console.
You get this as part of
Google Play Games Services.
And what it does, it's
a very clear picture.
Maybe clear is not the right
word, because at the beginning,
it looks a bit confusing.
But it gives you a very
clear picture of what
your-- how players
interact with your game.
Every symbol here has a meaning.
Every symbol is a
different action
that a user has
taken in your game.
So one symbol represents
a purchase event.
Another symbol
represents completing
a level or an achievement.
And you see the
sequence of actions
that every user has taken.
This is a sample of your users.
It's up to 100.
And you can see
how they interact.
The first thing you
can do with this report
is see what action lead
to what matters to you.
For example, what have
they done before they
made their first purchase?
Or what have they
done before churning?
And so you can optimize
your game overall
and see if you have any issues.
But where it becomes
even more powerful
and relevant to this talk
is that you can actually
filter this report by
different types of users.
So, for example, users that have
made a purchase and users that
haven't made a purchase or
that have spent some amount,
and users that have spent more.
And you can start understanding
the differences, what really
are the different
behaviors, what they're
looking for in your game,
depending on what type
of category of users they are.
So it's a very good way
to get some insights
and design your game based
on what type of users
you have and not just
one size fits all.
In similar reports,
these similar insights
you can get from the
Funnel Report, which
is also available in
Developer Console for free
if you integrate Google
Play Game Services.
And again, we take
these database
and them signing in through
their Google account.
So you should make it
easy for them to do that.
And what it does,
it shows you how
users go through different steps
of a funnel that you create.
So you can set any
event you want.
It could be steps in a tutorial.
It could levels in your game.
It could be a series
of random events
that matter to you as a
sequence in your game.
And you can see
how they progress
through each of these
steps and where they leave.
So that is, actually,
again, very powerful
overall for your game to find
friction points and roadblocks
that you can improve
and get rid of.
But again, this is
much more useful
when you start filtering it
by different types of users
because you can understand
what users have problems
in your game and what types
of problems they have,
depending on which
group they belong to.
As you see here,
it's highlighted,
the different types of audiences
that you can filter for,
in this case, if they spent less
than $3, spent more than $10,
they haven't spent at all.
And you can see what are the
key differences between them.
So this is already on
itself a quite impactful way
to rethink your game.
This is an example
from Max Games,
who recently used this report to
improve the game "Stick Wars--
Legacy."
And they reduced churn
in level 6 by 40%
just by using these insights.
But again, the
important thing here
is that these tools give
you a very simple way
to understand what are the
differences in your users, what
are they looking
for, and what are
the most important
types of users you
want to optimize your game for.
So you can apply
the key principles
that Adam talked about, what are
the big things that they want
to look for and
how can we please
as many users as possible,
keeping one game and one on one
experience.
But when it comes
to target them,
you need much more
detailed information
about every user and not
just a sample of users.
And that's where Players
Stats API comes into play.
You can integrate
this for free again,
and it's quite simple
I've been told.
And you get a lot of
information about your users
not only basic stats
that you normally
expect from these kind of APIs,
like session, and suspense
percentile, and average session
length, and number of sessions,
or days since last played,
all very important information
to understand what type
of user that user is,
but also you get
predictive analytics.
This is super cool.
This is probability from zero
to one for the user to spend
and the probability from
zero to one to churn.
We even recently introduced
two more granular metrics,
same predictive analytics,
so the probability
to become a high spender and
to spends in the next 28 days.
And what is really
cool about this
is that this
information is not just
calculated based on the behavior
of your players in your game,
but your players on other games.
So you get the power of
what our machine learning
and the information that
we get by them signing in
in all these games, and you can
use it to better target them.
What I mean by
better target them
is very clear in
this simple example,
but I think it's very powerful.
This is Invent Venture.
And they use the
Player Stats API
to make sure that as they grew
their rewarded ads revenues.
They didn't cannibalize their
in-app purchase revenues.
So what they did is that
they showed reward ads only
to the users that were
less likely to spend,
and they didn't show
them to the users that
were actually likely to spend.
So in a way, they tried to
monetize different users
based on their purchase
behavior and their propensity
to spend, again, without having
to do much on the analytics
side because they just got an
input from the Player Stats
API.
And that input
was based not only
on those players'
behavior in their game,
but also on all the
other games that they've
played that add Google
Play Games Services.
But that's just an example.
You got some ideas
from Fred's talk
on how you can actually start
thinking about different types
of users and target them.
Here are some other ideas
just how to use this data.
You can, for example,
target high session length
and frequency, so basically the
most avid players on your game
with a reward.
And you can get
information about them,
again, through the
Player Stats API.
You can also target users
of that high risk of churn
with some time-limited
special item
that they can get if they
get back to your game
as soon as possible.
You can reach them
with a notification.
You know who they are because
they have a high probability
to churn, and you get that
from the Player Stats API.
You can then target
users that are
more likely to spend
with a special offer just
to make sure that you
convert them and customize
that bundle or that
offer to be a bigger one,
make a bigger value
with a higher price
point for the ones that are
likely to become high spenders.
So you get the idea.
Again, most of the ideas
will come from Fred's part
of the presentation.
But now you have
the tools to start
without having to do much
in terms of analytics
and understanding users.
So the sky's the limit here.
But I want to leave you with
the last very basic concept
that I saw many developers, even
the ones that are getting very
advanced in this,
sometimes they oversee this
and forget about it.
The biggest difference
between users
is still where they're based.
Country matters a lot.
I know it sounds
intuitive, but sometimes
with machine learning
and analytics and all
that we forget about the basics.
And especially when
it comes to pricing,
you need to make sure
that your price is
relevant for the country
where the user is based.
And if you do A/B
testing for your pricing,
you should do it
at country level.
We think that this is a very
important part of monetizing,
and that's why we've
been also addressing
this with introducing
new minimum prices
for some currencies
and some markets that
have different higher
prices, essentially to say,
and different purchasing power.
And these are some
of the big ones.
In total, we introduced
this for 12 countries,
both in EMEA and Asia.
So check it out in
the Developer Console.
You have access now
to a much lower price
that you can use
in those markets
where conversion
is more difficult,
but you can still
extrapolate value from that.
So thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]